a brand new map ragnarok new
customization and fortnight becoming
more than battle royale let's look at
those leaks and rumors all about
fortnight chapter 2 hello and welcome to
PlayStation great before every season we
get together and go over all those leaks
and insane theories we see out there and
try to break down if they are legit
anyway please smash colder tomorrow in
the fortnight shop oh damn there is no
pot night shop right now well instead
why don't you subscribe and get me to 1
million subscribers this year in return
I'll hit you with a face reveal perfect
for Halloween
I mean that I'm so ugly it will scare
your grin
anyway let's do this
let's start with the event what a mind
that was rockets pounding the skyline
with riffs before the meteor was
transported over to the Nexus and
smashed the zero point into submission
resulting in a black hole until the next
season arrives firstly what an awesome
thing to do to have the guts to take
down your own game knowing gamers will
be forced to play something different in
the meantime is insane but the hype
building towards a new season is now
unstoppable at the end of the event we
saw multiple items dragged into the
black hole with us meaning we can expect
those items to play an important part
next season the food fight isn't over as
the tomato head flies into the black
hole and the battle bus was here - as
every year the crash site changes place
so now it looks like it's on a new map I
tried to find my best friend Hut watch
in this vacuum but alas I couldn't see
it so now's the time to say goodbye hot
watch you will go down in fortnight
folklore since this moment a code has
slowly been revealed which reads I was
not alone others were outside the loop
this was not calculated the moment is
now inevitable but did you know if you
weren't in the event early enough you
got this cutscene instead
but it gets even better if you were in
the menu but didn't select battle royale
you receive these voice lines I have a
cold
that is why my voice sounds
interdimensional everything is fine
there's nothing to worry about but if
something were wrong I would know you
know I'll fix it
the universe is fine time also fine no
further questions I need a minute and
then an additional series of minutes
don't open the door
there's nothing to worry about if you
don't recognize that voice it's ray a
robot from save the world
in a recent theory we looked at the save
the world timeline and the Battle Royale
timeline joining together to make one
cohesive story similar events have
happened in both timelines and the
kicker to this is the father of those V
books we all love dr. Vin de Minh he's
key to the plot in save the world but
from what we've heard the voices on
those tapes in battle royale it's him
the og scientist is dr. Vin de Minh so
is now the time for save the world and
Battle Royale to combine to make one
super video que I truly believe that
many people and I include myself in this
don't play as much Battle Royale as they
once did the map changes and the story
that underpins all this keeps them
engaged though the brilliance of season
four has remained the high point of this
entire journey we've been on due to how
easy the storyline is to follow and the
mind-blowing events it was so good that
six seasons later the event was copied
to attract those people yet again by
combining the story of both PvE and PvP
game modes will ensure these players
remain engaged what do you think about
save the world and Battle Royale stories
now intertwining please let me know your
thoughts in the comments I'll be
stalking down there but let's go back to
battle royale as that's what you're here
for right a few weeks ago a potential
leak told us about new locations which
could arise next season
beachy bluffs Camp Cod dirty docks a
frenzied farm Polly hedges lazy lake
mountain meadow power plant
slurpy swamp sunny shores weed ping
woods ok so a lot of those sound like a
six-year-old has created them but others
sound like sides theories to me all
these would tie into a new map and they
also follow the naming conventions which
epic actually stopped using towards the
end of last season moisty palms everyone
that must be the worst name of a
location in the history of mankind we
have no proof if these leaks are real so
we'll have to see what happens later
this week exciting times
[Music]
but now the moment I've been waiting for
it's time to introduce thick skins into
battle royale for a few years now I've
let you know I like the bigger skins in
fortnight save the world Kyle as he
looks like me fan penny the digital girl
of my dreams
that bunny romper suit Wow gorgeous well
fought night battle royale introduced
their first thick's in this season in
the scientists
he's far easier to hit so yes there's a
drawback to this but in terms of
cosmetic brilliance he's freakin awesome
in creative the size of the character is
less important and there's so many
people love this mode in fortnight there
is no better time than right now
to introduce my girl penny and Thicke
boy Kyle what do you say if you with me
can you write team Thicke in the
comments below I will try and find you
for the last few seasons I've been going
on about loadouts
a preset character with all the
customization set ready to go well why
do I keep bringing this up let me tell
you a story back in April I went to an
event which had many epic employees
there one of them let slip in a
conversation that loadouts are ready to
be implemented but now six months later
we are still waiting another game I
enjoy dauntless has already implemented
this and it's a godsend it really is
it's great so where is the fortnight
version I now believe I have an answer
for this I think it's been held back for
version 2.0 a fortnight season 11
fortnight chapter 2 whatever you want to
call it and this is backed up by ninja
you may not have heard of him he's a
small but upcoming for my player who
recently visited Epic Games to try out
something new and let's slip in a stream
that the UI the user interface and the
menus are changing next season
coincidence I think not by having such a
long downtime epic have to return with
something massive and yeah a new map is
a pretty big thing but also a new menu
system and hopefully those loadouts we
need we need them
[Music]
and speaking of customization have you
seen what other games are implementing
to monetize their content apex leggins
has skydiving emotes which have no
bearing on the game but are fun and
unique and then we have another game
called realm Royale do you remember it
well have you seen what they've done
this season customizable markers when a
teammate puts a marker down in watt
night we get a pretty boring light or
compare that to realm royale what you
fought night ripped off these other
games again to take this and offer even
more customization to us all the only
other thing I can imagine is selectable
hats or charms for weapons like in
Rainbow six by doing this epic will make
more money and players will feel even
more independent more unique more
original and segue by using code and
amaru when you buy anything in the shop
you get a shout out like these legends
thanks you guys for supporting me I
still have a mountain of DMS to go
through so if you're not on this list
now don't worry I will get round to you
and you'll be in the next video
cheers leggins okay this next one is bat
crazy it really is but I kinda like
these kind of theories so did you see
the random trailer that epic put out
about Jonesy getting on the battle bus
with 99 tomato headed freaks well
there's a lot to unpack here this
trailer in my opinion represents
Ragnarok the end of the world yes I know
I sound special but let me break it down
first the name of the video bus fuller
tomatoes why would fortnight's suddenly
start using slang in titles fuller
that's weird isn't it right well did you
know that fuller is found in Norse myth
she's a goddess
who kept the secrets of Odin's wife
freak off free oh if you prefer next the
battle bus is found in a forest which is
very different from usual in Norse myth
this is the mere cover ah damn it I
can't say that word here's that word on
screen
anyway this forest has prevented many
from leaving described as being black
with only a circle of light to walk
towards does that sound familiar to you
oh and this weirdness continues have you
heard of Loki of course you have you've
seen Marvel films well mr. Loki is a
trickster god who uses
shifting to gain an advantage
psychologically he definitely achieves
it here even the bus driver is a tomato
okay long story short in for tonight we
have a character set known as Ragnarok
we've seen a Viking village begin to
take over the map and now we have
multiple nods to Viking culture and
mythology oh yeah than the end of the
world
just like the tale of Ragnarok okay I
told you this was a crazy theory but I
thought I'd share it all the same
what night chapter two must bring new
mechanics to the game to make the
downtime worth it but what could those
new mechanics be judging by the leaked
images boats are coming but will this
mean swimming is coming to again the
hints have been there for seasons that
water themed content is coming remember
the season with the pirates how random
was that and he went no where could they
be holding something back there to come
back to next season
oh maybe fishing that links him with
water I suppose there's always some
silly updater did you see and why was
football taken out of soccer if you
prefer it has to be to make room for the
balls to be added to our loadouts this
also could see an updated graphic system
added to the game I don't know if you've
noticed that the game has received many
graphical overhauls but they're so tiny
you don't notice these are all
accumulative if you compare season 1 to
season 10 sees a nexus story you can see
the changes will season 11 make more
than a subtle change to this and while
we're talking about changes I believe we
will get an FLV slider a field of view
it's already available in most of for
tonight's competitors games and changes
the feel of fighting massively deciding
how much you can see around you is key
to battle awareness but by zooming out
slightly it can be harder to aim perfect
dilemma for pros remember stretch dress
that was disgusting that was awful back
then and a continuation of this
what about first-person view if you
didn't know save the world has first
person view built-in but not many people
use it but it is there they've already
implemented it could this be taken over
into battle royale would you try a
first-person version of fortnight
building is nauseating I'll tell you
that much but it does change so much
about the game it almost feels
completely different like a new game and
finally here's my biggest prediction for
the season and I have nothing to back it
up with fortnight will become far more
than a battle royale game as a genre
battle royale took over the world of
gaming and will likely continue to do so
for a few more years at least but
players have already begun to move away
from this genre from epics actions over
the last year we can already see that
they are aware of trends and will adapt
fortnight to any game style have you
heard of Dreams dreams is a ps4 game
sort of slush creator which you can make
anything with in I've seen first person
shooters created racing destruction
games made 2d platformers 3d platformers
puzzle games I even saw Mario Kart
created and a Horus Tim - I could
legitimately just list off all the
things you can make in dreams the point
I'm making though is that fortnight can
use this as a cue and allow us to create
more content on our creative islands but
at the moment they are too small to do
much with this will likely change next
season for fortnight to continue leading
the way it must adapt how it offers
content and ultimately become a second
life to gamers like a Playstation home
but it's actually fun a place to meet up
and experience things with friends
across the globe remember the driving
cinema why couldn't that be a real
cinema do you know what I mean is this
too far-fetched okay I'll shut up
all the foundations are there so expect
fortnight to become more than a be our
shooter fortnight is here to stay
so there we have it what do you think if
half this stuff is true what night
chapter 2 will be insanely good but what
do you think will happen I'd love to
know your thoughts I'll definitely be in
the comments below
reading through your texts if this was
useful please think about pressing like
and help me reach a larger audience I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade if the
store ever comes back think about you
think old Adam aru if not I'll see you
next season thanks for your time see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]